the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
as you all know i am writing my own
version of game of thrones season 9.
in this video i will show you what
happens in the second episode
as this season slowly starts to unfold
the name of this episode is
the weirwoods of westeros there are a
lot of scenes in this episode so let's
get started right away
shall we begin the first scene of the
second episode begins in the middle of
the night
we can see there is what looks like
seven men walking along the beach
away from their ship six of these men
are holding something very large
as they slowly shift their feet across
the sand
we follow them for a few moments before
they finally walk under the full
moonlight
allowing us to see who they are and what
they're holding these men are all
dressed in their unsolid uniforms
the six men are holding a casket as they
are following greyworm
who approaches another man waiting for
them at the end of the beach
this unknown man also has several men of
his own standing behind him
as grey war moves forward the unknown
man raises one of his hands
signaling for them to stop greyworm and
his men ignore
the request the man then shouts out what
business do you gentlemen have on the
island of
noth greyworm waits until he is standing
right before him
then says fulfilling a promise the other
unsullied men set the casket down in the
sand
grey worm looks at it and says this is
missandei
this is her home this is where she would
want to be
this is where she belongs the unknown
man says missandei is not a name we are
familiar with
who was she grey worm looks back down at
the casket and says
my one true love the unknown man says i
see
well in that case allow me and my men to
help you
we shall lay my sandy of noth at rest
during the following dusk
follow me there is somewhere you must
stay while you're here
grey worms men grab the casket then lift
it back up from the sand
they begin following the men over to a
small building made out of stone
when they reach the building the unknown
man swings the door open and says
this is where you and your men must stay
for the evening grey worm examines the
small stone structure
he notices there aren't any windows he
also notices there is only one door
and this door opens only from the
outside greyworm says
what is it why do we stay in this the
man says this
is our shelter for our special visitors
greyworm has a confused look on his face
he says shelter a shelter from what the
man smiles
and says you're not very familiar with
the island of noth
are you there are over a hundred
different kinds of butterflies on this
island
and they're the only thing that stops
soldiers like you from slaughtering or
enslaving
everyone that inhabits it we are not
known for our skill on the battlefield
but the butterflies are the messengers
of our lord you're lucky you and your
men
arrived here at nightfall you must stay
in the shelter until you hear a knock on
the door
if this door opens while the sun is in
the sky we will be needing more caskets
on the morrow
you understand greyworm nods his head
then him
and his men step inside in the following
scene
we are back out beyond the wall where
the wildlings had settled for the night
everyone is now awake gathered around
the fire looking at jon snow
who is still sitting beneath the
weirwood jon looks visibly shaken
as he takes another long sip of his ale
ghost is now sitting next to john
the albino direwolf is glaring into the
eyes of the weirwood
we can still see the reflection of the
fire in his own glowing red eyes
ghost and the werewood have a striking
resemblance
they're both white as bone with eyes as
red as blood
some of the wildlings look frightened
when they notice the harris standing up
on the direwolf's back
as he begins sniffing the ground around
the werewood
jon snow finally looks back at the
werewolf himself
wondering if what he saw when he closed
his eyes was real
or only a dream as jon focuses on the
weirwood
he notices something red is running out
of its eyes it almost looks as if it's
blood
he looks away when he sees tormund as
walking over with more ale
he sits down next to jon then fills his
cup back up
what's wrong snow did that dragon lady
of yours come back to kill you in your
sleep said tormund
who now has a smirk on his face john
doesn't find that amusing
he says maybe she is before he takes
another long drink of his ale
tormund throws his arm around jon's
shoulder then says you have nothing to
fear snow
my dreams have been haunting me for
years none of my enemies have ever
killed me
when i'm awake john doesn't respond
right away
he looks into the fire for a few moments
then says this wasn't a normal dream
something felt different about it i
heard a voice
now tormund takes a big gulp of his own
ale and says half of the wildlings here
have voices in their heads no
what of it i'm serious says john it
wasn't my voice that i heard
a wildling woman suddenly stands up then
walks over to sit down next to them
she looks at john and says i would like
to know what the voice said
well says john it said look for me
did you hear anything else what did you
see said the wildling woman
john looks over at the werewolf again
then says i saw that
only this one was bigger much bigger it
looked like it was out here somewhere
beyond the wall
the werewolf set on a hill overlooking
the snow-covered ground
the wildling woman smiles as she says i
know where that is
i have seen it before good says john
make sure everyone is ready at dawn you
will lead the way
the woman stands up then gives a nod in
agreement before she walks away
jon now looks over at ghost who is still
sniffing around at the ground under the
weirwood
he kneels down beside him as he runs his
fingers through his white fur
john examines the ground looking for
whatever it is that ghost can smell
he doesn't see anything but dirt and
leaves but he suddenly notices the same
thing ghost does
jon's eyes go wider as he looks over at
tormund
do you smell that says john the only
thing i can smell is this burning fire
says tormund who now walks over by jon
and ghost
he also watches ghosts as he sniffs
around at the ground what does he smell
snow
i don't see anything jon looks back at
the weirwood and stares into its
blood-red eyes
this scene ends when jon says it smells
like death
in this next scene we are back in
winterfell below the castle and its
crypt
we are following sansa the maester and a
few of the stark men as they head
further and further down into the
darkness
the look of fear can be seen on sansa's
face she has never gone this far before
the faces on the statues are of men she
does not recognize
the dead starks look meaner and meaner
the deeper they go
roma is there your grace the statues end
just right up ahead
said one of the stark guardsmen we can
start to see where this level of the
[ __ ] was once blocked off by the fallen
rubble
there are large stones and mounds of
dirt stacked up along the side of the
wall
where the stark guardsmen had moved it
when they reached the last statue
sansa stops right in front of it she
says this is the farthest any stark i
know has ever gone
my father said it had been blocked off
for many years even before he was born
sansa holds up her light as she looks
around the cavernous vault
this isn't only where the statues end
your grace this is where the candles
and the stone ends as well said the star
guardsmen what do you mean this is where
the stones end
said sansa thousands and thousands of
stones were set down here
all throughout the ceiling and the walls
to stop everything from collapsing
in on itself whoever made this [ __ ]
stopped here
this is as low as it goes this is where
the stones end
said the stark guardsman sansa looks at
the last statue then says
maybe it was him she holds her light
over the statue
as she looks at its face sansa is
suddenly startled by what she sees
the statue's face seems oddly familiar
but there is something unsettling about
it as well
sansa feels as if its eyes are looking
through her into her soul
the front of this statue looks like it's
in fairly good shape considering how old
it must be
however some of it is missing the entire
back half of the statue is now gone
sanzo forces herself to look away we can
now see there is a name
engraved into the bottom of the statue
it says
brandon stark and right below the name
it also says
the king of winter sansa grabs something
that was laying across his lap
she holds it up into the light for them
to see it's the handle from a very very
old sword
sansa says my father always used to say
swords were laid across the laps of each
statue to help keep the vengeful spirits
locked within the crypt the iron from
this one must have rusted away many
years ago
i'm not sure it would be of any use now
she drops the broken handle onto the
ground
then walks forward the stark guardsman
holds up his light
illuminating what lies ahead he says the
drawings we found
are right this way your grace sansa
looks down into the dark abyss
whoever made the underground passage
must have spent years digging it out
you really can't see much ahead but it
looks like it goes on for as far as the
eyes can see
sansa says is it safe you said there are
no stones in here supporting it from
falling in
what if it collapses while we're in
there i wouldn't worry about that your
grace
the walls and ceiling feel rock solid
everything moving forward is frozen
sansa the maester and the stark
guardsmen move ahead
the scene ends as they begin fading away
into the darkness
in the following scene we are back in
king's landing the sound of steel
hitting steel can be heard from inside
the red key
we see swords clash then spring apart
then clash again
as brienne and podrick dance across the
map of westeros on the floor
brienne moves to the right but podrick
blocks her with a quick sidestep and
drives her back the other way
brienne now grabs the sword with both
hands then rushes forward aggressively
she brings the sword up over her head
then brought it back down hard
and fast as podrick began to backpedal
he brings up his own sword but her blow
easily knocks it away
he sucks in a deep breath then charges
ahead
this sent brienne staggering as she went
railing on her heels
she raises her sword but podrick knocked
it away then slashed at her again
as brienne regains her footing podrick
lifted his sword high above his head
but he suddenly brings it back down
again when he notices samwell is in the
room
watching them sam is looking at them
with a big grin across his face
holding a book in his hands sam says you
know from over here
it looked like he was winning that makes
podrick smile from ear to ear
brienne looks annoyed and out of breath
she says he wasn't winning
i was only giving him a chance to know
what that feels like he's good
but he's not that good sam then says
well when he does finally beat you
you will only have yourself to blame i
agree says brianne
he got all those moves from me sam then
says i am looking for king bran
there is something he should see he's in
his chambers right now says brienne
follow me i will take you to him sam
smiles then gives a head nod
we follow sam and brianne as they walk
across the painted map on the floor
the attack from daenerys and drogon has
still left a large crack on the floor
splitting westeros in half when they
reach what was once the stairs that lead
to the king's chambers
we can see they are now smooth in the
fashion of a ramp
this makes it easier for them to
maneuver bran around the castle
when sam and brienne reach the door she
knocks loudly before she says
your grace bran doesn't answer brienne
knocks again
then again louder than before there's
still no answer
your grace is everything alright says
sam there is no sound coming from inside
the chambers
brienne now looks worried so she opens
the door herself
they see bran is sitting there in
silence facing the fire in the hearth
his head is leaning back slightly with
his eyes rolled back
when he hears them in the room his head
snaps forward and his eyes roll back
down
i'm sorry for barging in here like this
your grace but i thought something was
wrong
bran looks over at them acknowledging
that they're there but he looks back at
the fire without saying anything
sam walks across the room while still
holding the book in his hands
he sits down next to bran and says there
is something i wanted to show you your
grace
he holds out the book so brian can see
it sam says
i found this book on the legends of the
long night while i was at the citadel
at first i didn't think it had any
useful information
but i noticed something interesting on
the front of it i was hoping i could
find out its origin
i've already wrote a letter to the
citadel asking them if they know how old
it is
and where it's from or who wrote it
would you be able to help me your grace
sam holds the book out even further here
look for yourself
what do you think your grace bran
finally looks down at the book
he grabs it from sam's hands then
studies the image on its cover
he looks at it for a few moments but
then he starts running his finger along
the book
outlining the skeleton looking figure on
the front does that look familiar your
grace
do you see the dagger in its hand bran
still doesn't say anything
sam looks back at breanne somewhat
confused
bran looks like he's in deep thought as
he runs his finger along the dagger on
the book
sam says what do you think your grace is
there anything you can tell me
after a few more moments of silence bran
now looks up at sam
with his glaring eyes bran says no
then he throws the book in the fire sam
and brienne are shocked they knew bran
was a little strange
but they've never seen him show any
signs of aggression before
sam looks into the fire horrified as he
watches the book burn
the skeleton-looking figure on the front
of the book gets consumed by the flames
why would you do that your grace that
book wasn't mine it belongs to the
citadel
it might have been their only records of
the long night bran doesn't say anything
right away he just sits there watching
as what's left of the book disappears
into the flames and smoke
brienne steps forward and says are you
okay your grace
bran looks at both of them then says you
said it yourself sam
that book had no useful information but
your grace
that was until i saw bran doesn't let
him finish his sentence
because he suddenly says that will be
all for now i would like to be left
alone
you are dismissed brienne and sam look
at each other
they are stunned by what just happened
the scene ends as they're walking out of
the room
in the following scene we are back out
at sea on one of the house stark ships
the scene opens up below the deck in its
main cabin the dead man who was sent to
kill arya is still laying on the floor
surrounded by dried blood arya stark is
standing over his body
she's discussing what happened with
roughly a dozen stark men
as well as the captain and others who
work on the ship
do any of you recognize this man do any
of you know his name
do any of you know how long he has been
with us get a good look at him
he has a very distinctive scar across
his face
surely someone must know who he is all
eyes are now on the dead man laying on
the floor
now that arya is getting a good look at
the man she notices he's much older than
he first appeared to be
most of the hair on his head and face is
grey although he is larger than arya he
looks frail
he looks like he might be 60 years old
the captain says
i do not recognize him my lady i am
responsible for every man and woman who
board this ship
yet i don't remember ever seeing this
man a few of the stark men speak
up as well each of them say they don't
know who the man is either
arya shakes her head still somewhat in
denial of the circumstances
what did he want my lady says the
captain did he say anything
arya says he wanted me dead he was
hiding behind my door
waiting for me to be alone he said
arya takes a deep breath then exhales
before she finishes her sentence
he said my brother bran sent him here to
kill me
one of the stark men spits on the dead
man's body then says
i'm sorry my lady the man is a liar why
would your own brother
our king want you dead it doesn't make
any sense
i know says arya i don't want to believe
it myself the captain then says
maybe someone else sent him who else
would want you dead
do you have any other enemies my lady
with a slight smirk on her face
arya says they're all dead my sister
sansa said bran
sees things now he has visions he knows
things
he's not the same brother i grew up with
he's different now
but i still don't think he would want me
dead the captain says
what should we do now my lady arya says
i need to speak with my brother right
away
i have to find out what's happening
should we stop somewhere soon
and send a raven my lady said the
captain arya shakes her head and says no
i don't want anyone in king's landing
knowing what happened on this ship
not yet if my brother bran really does
want me dead
i don't want him to know i'm on my way
back the captain nods his head in
agreement
then says very well my lady no ravens
he looks down at the dead body on the
floor and says what do you want us to do
with him
arya says throw his body into the sea
the fish can feed on him
four of the stark men lift the lifeless
body from the floor
each of them are holding either an arm
or a leg we follow them out of the cabin
and down the hallway until they reach
the main deck
the men swing his body up onto the
railing then they roll him off the ship
into the sea below they stand there
watching and waiting for a moment
until they see the man's body fully
submerge under the water
the men walk away back below the deck we
now see one of house stark's banners
flapping in the wind
high up on the ship right before the
scene ends a raven lands on the stark
banner
its eyes are as black as obsidian but
then we see them
flash white then black again in the next
scene we are back out beyond the wall
we are following jon ghost and the group
of wildlings as they are now heading out
further north
through the haunted forest the wildling
woman is now riding on the back of jon's
horse
as she guides them to the massive
werewood he saw while he was sleeping
as they're moving through the forest
john looks over at tormund who is only a
few feet away on his horse and says
you were right about what you said back
there right about what
says tormund about daenerys coming back
to kill me john said
the werewood wasn't the only thing i saw
while i was sleeping
i did see daenerys in my dream she was
inside a massive fire
just standing there with a hole in her
chest it felt as if she was looking
right at me
dreams are a funny thing snow some folks
say they've had dreams of
all of us living inside the blue eye of
a giant named macumber
says tormund they don't mean anything
the wildling woman says
i have had dreams of me flying on the
back of an eagle
maybe you're right says john maybe it
doesn't mean anything
this didn't feel like only a dream
though it felt like something else
you said you stabbed her in the heart
you said you saw her die
then her dragon left with her body i bet
she was dropped out at sea
says tormund john looks over at him
again and says
that doesn't mean anything either you
and i both know that dead don't always
stay dead
the night king raised the dead by the
thousands jon then sets his hand
over his own chest and says i was also
stabbed in the heart
yet here i am we watch as jon ghost
and the wildlings continue to move
forward deeper into the haunted forest
we then see a raven circling around in
the sky just up ahead
right before the scene ends in the
following scene we are back in
winterfell below the castle and its
crypt
sansa the maester and the star guardsmen
are still walking further into the crypt
into the dark abyss their flickering
light is illuminating the walkway
we can see the ground is frozen there
are icicles and ice crystals hanging
down from the ceiling
we can also see what looks like white
and red veins running along the ceiling
when sansa notices them she says what
are those
the maester says those are the roots of
the werewood your grace
the drawings are right up ahead said the
stark guardsmen about 100 feet in front
of them
there are three more stark guardsmen
holding candles in their hands
as they examine all the drawings on the
wall when they finally reach the three
stark men
one of them says we are sorry you had to
come all the way down here your grace
but we knew you would want to see this
for yourself sansa raises her arm
to hold her light up near the wall we
watch as her eyes scan back and forth
studying each of the images we see sansa
taking a deep breath
when she notices something that does
look familiar the first drawing shows a
castle
that looks sort of like winterfell only
smaller than what it is now
there is also a man in front of that
castle who looks very similar to the
statue in the crypt
sonza says that looks like brandon stark
the old king of winter
the maestro says i think you're right
your grace he does have a striking
resemblance to the statue
right next to this is another drawing of
a large weirwood
with a man in front of it surrounded by
what looks like a dozen members of the
children of the forest
there is another drawing next to that
this one shows one child of the forest
shaking hands with what looks like the
night king only this one has a beard
like the one we saw on dragonstone the
next drawing shows a very large
grove of werewoods all in a circle
facing inward
in the center of this large grove of
werewoods is another werewood
only this one is much bigger than the
rest it looks like it might be the
biggest weirwood in westeros
now this next drawing shows a beheading
there is one member of the children of
the forest who looks very old
he has long white hair with a very long
white beard
in his hand he is holding the head of
what looks like another
member of the children of the forest
sansa holds her light up higher
then moves it along the wall a little
further there is one final drawing on
the wall
this one shows a skeleton looking figure
holding what looks like a nice sword in
one hand
with a dagger in its other sansa lets
out another deep breath
it's so cold down here you can see the
mist in the air as she exhales
i don't know what these mean says sansa
she looks at everyone else standing
there and says
do any of you know what these are i'm
sorry your grace but
we do not says one of the star guardsmen
the maester says
do any of your men know how to draw i'm
sure we can find someone who can
said the stark guardsmen why i want
someone to make a sketch of these images
i will send it to the citadel maybe they
can decipher the drawings there
said the maester sansa looks at the
maester and says
do you understand any of these have you
seen any of these drawings before
the maester lifts his arm and holds his
finger out to one of the images
he says that one your grace the large
werewood surrounded by the weirwood
grove
there is only one location in westeros
that i know of that would have a
weirwood of that size
the scene ends right as sansa says where
now in my final scene of this episode we
are back across the narrow sea in essos
in the city of atlantis the sun is just
now beginning to set
as we see an even larger crowd gather
below the red temple of relore
the streets of the city are now flooded
with thousands of followers of the lord
of light
drogon is sitting atop the building
overlooking everyone below
the dragon lets out another thunderous
scream
it's equally exciting and frightening
because everyone knows
they are witnessing a historic event the
high-ranking members of verlor
who are all still dressed in their red
robes are all gathered in a circle
around daenerys's body
they have her laid out across a stone
block in front of the massive brazier
they're all chanting something in high
valyria their chanting grows louder and
louder
as dark clouds begin to form in the sky
above
everyone in the crowd ducks down when
they hear an ear splitting crack of
thunder in the distance
violent flashes of lightning begin
emerging in the sky
the crowd below grows frantic as the
chanting gets louder
and the storm above grows stronger the
ruby necklace on kinvara's neck is
glowing
so red hot it starts burning the symbol
into her skin
a red bolt of lightning strikes down
into the middle of the brazier
which causes a small fire to begin
burning inside of it again
suddenly the chanting stops all of the
high ranking members of relore
remove their hoods then they take a step
forward all of them reach their hands
under daenerys's body
then lift her up into the sky they walk
over to the burning brazier
the crowd below erupts into chaos when
they realize what's about to happen
daenerys's lifeless body is thrown into
the flames
now all of the red robes gather in a
circle around the brazier
they remove their necklaces then throw
them inside
we watch as the rubies burst open into a
red liquid that almost looks like blood
fire and blood the small flames are now
several different shades of red
and orange kinvara looks up at drogon
her eyes are now glowing red as well in
a loud voice
kinvara shouts dracarus drogon spreads
his wings
and lets out another deafening scream
the fire unleashes from his mouth into
the brazier below
there are men and women in the crowd who
are weeping with joy
the flames reach high into the air as
they are licking at the night sky
the storm begins to settle as the clouds
begin to move
they reveal there was a full moon hiding
behind them
a blood moon everyone is now staring
into the fire
the reflection of the flames can be seen
in kinvara's glowing red eyes
everything is silent except for the
crackling of the fire
suddenly we hear the sound of thousands
gasping for air
as they see a black silhouette emerge in
the flames
as the fire dies down we can see a nude
body standing in the center of the
brazier
there is a large stab wound in their
chest there is some black smoke rising
out of it
the episode ends as daenerys emerges
through the flames in smoke
[Music]
[Music]
you